hey crazies I've been meaning to do a
video and white dwarves for a while what
what no no wait - warp stars I did my 90
some page thesis on it it lives in the
shelf over here they're one of those
weird astronomical objects that can't be
understood without quantum mechanics
let's start at the beginning no no no
too far back I mean we're white dwarves
come from it stop it there are three
types of stellar corpses the big stars
leave behind black holes and the medium
ones leave behind neutron stars it's the
small ones that leave behind white dwarf
different low mass stars live slightly
different lives so they can end up with
white dwarves made of slightly different
thing but there's still white dwarfs the
vast majority of active stars in the
present universe are low mass stars
about 70% of them are faint red dwarfs
the point is eventually we're going to
have a bunch of white dwarfs floating
around we should probably understand
them
classically these things shouldn't even
exist gravity should collapse them into
black hole but we know that doesn't
happen we can see some of them through
telescopes so we know they exist
the problem is balance smaller stuff
like these ice cubes don't collapse
under their own gravity because the
bonds the intermolecular forces hold the
atoms in place you can say the same
thing for stuff as big as asteroids or
even planets but stars are different
they're so massive that their self
gravity breaks the matter down molecules
and even atoms fall apart and they
become a giant ball of plasma stars have
something else to keep them from
collapsing radiation pressure as the
gravity pulls inward the fusion in the
core releases light and that light
exerts an outward pressure to balance
gravity it's what we call hydrostatic
equilibrium because it behaves like a
fluid with balanced forces white dwarves
are kind of in-between planets and stars
they're a dead star meaning no more
fusion and no more radiation pressure
but they're way too massive for
molecules to hold up actually if white
dwarfs are white and they're emitting
light so there is radiation pressure yes
yes but not nearly enough
radiation pressure depends heavily on
momentum and therefore energy and
ultimately frequency without fusion all
you get as the standard black body light
most of which is only in the visible
range that's pretty low energy fusion in
an active stellar core releases
high-energy gamma rays which have 10
million times the energy besides even
that black body light will eventually
bleed out into space and the white dwarf
will get cold and black and it still
won't collapse I really need to stop
being so depressing anyway if it's not
intermolecular forces and it's not
radiation pressure we need another
explanation and it comes from quantum
mechanics remember from the previous
video how you could only put two
electrons into a single atomic orbital
we called it the Pauli exclusion
principle the same rule applies here
it's just that white dwarf matter isn't
nearly as organized gravity is so strong
that molecules get crushed the atoms end
up overlapping so much that the
electrons don't belong to specific atoms
anymore they flow through the whole star
like it's one big sphere achill box
it's called degenerate matter because
it's of a lesser quality the quantum
states are very simple and a lot of them
share the same exact energy it's a total
mess but because of the poly exclusion
principle you can't have all the
electrons in the lowest energy there can
still only be two in each state so the
rest get forced into higher and higher
energy states just like in the atom this
behavior acts just like an outward
pressure we call it electron degeneracy
pressure for obvious reasons and it's
enough to hold back gravity up to a
limit the Chandrasekhar limit
anyway calculating this limit can be
tricky so we'll want to be careful what
we don't need to use general relativity
wall white dwarf stars are dense they
are neither massive enough nor dense
enough to require us to consider curved
space-time trust me I've done this
calculation both ways you get the same
result - we do need to use special
relativity remember how most of the
electrons are forced into higher energy
states well they're also forced into
higher momentum states which means most
of them are going haha I've also done
this calculation both ways you don't get
the same results now what was that last
thing all right we just need one more
piece of information the limiting factor
we need to know what makes the Pauli
exclusion principle fail that's where
the protons come in the more mass of the
white dwarf the stronger its gravity so
more massive white dwarves are actually
smaller in size their electrons are
confined into a smaller and smaller
space which means they're moving faster
and faster at some upper limit the
electrons are moving so fast that they
combine with the protons to make
neutrons it becomes the neutron star but
we're saving that for another video
the upper mass limit for a white dwarf
is is 1.4 times the mass of our Sun with
the diameter of only 1083 mile some
people describe it as a giant diamond in
space but this density is way past
Diamond so how many of you want to see
one of these up close let me know in the
comments thanks for liking and sharing
this video don't forget to subscribe if
you'd like to keep up with us and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy the featured comment comes
from cubies blog who asked why do atoms
seem to be the most stable with a filled
p orbital not really about the P
orbitals it's about the shells hole the
p orbital just tends to be on the
outside of the shell for that atom to
gain an electron and a bond it would
have to go up an entire extra energy
level that's not easy